what if the president of the united
states decides to launch a nuclear
strike
president trump started 2018 with a
tweet chiding north korea's leader kim
jong-un that
he too has a nuclear button and it's
bigger and more powerful
than kim's but launching a missile
involves much more than pushing a button
and really there is no button here's
what would actually happen
the president must first discuss the
plan with a group of military and
civilian advisors
that group includes the pentagon's
deputy director of operations and the
head of u.s strategic command
anyone else in the group is at the
president's discretion the call either
takes place in the white house situation
room or the president can be patched in
on a secure line
some of the advisors may try to change
the president's mind or even resign in
protest but ultimately the pentagon must
do whatever the commander-in-chief
orders that meeting with advisors can be
as short as 30 seconds
next the president gives the order to
launch but before the pentagon can
prepare the launch order it must first
verify that the person ordering the
strike is indeed the president
an officer in the pentagon's war room
reads what's known as a challenge code
for example delta echo the president
retrieves the biscuit
a laminated card the president or a
military aide carries at all times
and finds the matching response to the
challenge code for example
charlie zulu once the codes match the
launch order goes out
the war room prepares a message
containing the war plan time of launch
authentication codes and the codes
needed to unlock the missiles before
firing them
that message is only about 150
characters long
it's encoded encrypted and broadcast to
launch crews
at this point only about two to three
minutes may have passed since the
initial conference call
within seconds a submarine and five icbm
crews
in various underground bunkers receive
the launch orders they open safes and
compare their sealed authentication
system codes to those sent by the war
room this will confirm that the order is
authentic
if the codes match the crews enter the
war plan number into their launch
computers
they type additional code to unlock the
missiles and at the designated time of
launch
the five crews simultaneously turn a
launch key retrieved from their safe
it only takes two crews to launch so
three can refuse to do any of the prior
steps
and the missile or missiles will still
fire for missiles launched from a
submarine there is no second key the
crew has full power to launch
from here there is no turning back it's
been as little as five minutes from the
time the president decided to launch a
nuclear missile
to the time the missile or missiles
blast out of their silos it will take
submarine missiles an additional 15
minutes until they shoot out of their
tubes
once it fires a missile and its warhead
cannot be called back
you